it is so often said that it's the people
of the rural counties and just a few of
America's states who can swing the
country's Direction
[Applause]
with Virginia's Blue Ridge Mountains
Donald Trump has always found his
loyalists
there are of course those who will never
be moved
[Music]
but beyond this loyalty is there a line
a point of no return for the former
president
I don't think there's anybody that's in
politics that haven't done something
illegal or immoral Bobby Rosenberger is
a health worker and a trump voter what
do you make of of of the news now that a
jury in New York
has concluded that he's a sex offender I
think that everybody has made mistakes
in life
this happened years ago
up the road a conversation with Bobby
Jones it's a reminder to anyone who
might dismiss those who choose Trump
there is Nuance in their decisions that
I'm like I said he's a good man or bad
man all I'm saying is is that on my
stand of decency he at least did try to
help get rid of the abortion he did try
to help keep jobs going he did try to
keep jobs in the United States he tried
to look out for the people if he did
something immoral I don't agree with
that I think it's terrible but look at
what Biden's doing have mercy here in a
New York studio in another world the
woman who a jury concluded was sexually
assaulted by Donald Trump was deflecting
the mud already being thrown at her this
is not about the money this is about
getting my name back I'm overwhelmed
with happiness for the women of the
country it's really not about me so much
it's about every woman her lawyer
believes that in this video evidence
played in court Trump incriminated
himself with this remarkable
well that's what it's if you look over
the last million years I guess that's
been largely too not always but largely
true
unfortunately or fortunately
he continues to claim that he's never
met her
back in the place where it counts
another conversation which reveals so
much you know lead a small crucified
Trump so like I said they all dirty but
I like Trump better
[Laughter]
often feels like America has got to a
place where the polarization the
entrenchment the distrust of the other
is so deep that nothing will shift views
it's a place where there is now an
immunity to the unacceptable
if the question is can a sex offender be
president we'll hear the answer feels
like yes Mark Stone Sky News in Virginia